freiner la consommation de pétrole et
encourager les français à rouler propre
la question de l'énergie était aussi un
des points forts de l'intervention ce
matin du premier ministre dominique de
villepin qui souhaite limiter l'impact
de l'augmentation des carburants sur le
pouvoir d'achat des français
brigitte bois est faux en deux ans le
prix du fioul domestique a presque
doublé pour tous les foyers non
imposables qui utilisent ce mode de
chauffage le gouvernement va distribuer
sous forme de chèques une aide de 75
euros
comment diminuer les dépenses de
chauffage en encourageant par exemple
les énergies renouvelables
l'état va nous prendre en charge - ti de
la dépense pour tous ceux qui s'équipe
d'un chauffe eau solaire et pour tous
les travaux d'isolation dans les
logements anciens
le crédit d'impôt passe de 25 à 40%
autre souhait du premier ministre
encourage et des français à rouler
autrement pour tout achat d'une voiture
propre
le crédit d impôt augmente de 1525 à
2000 euros pour développer l'utilisation
de ce type de voiture le gouvernement
lance un programme de recherche de 100
millions d'euros
l'objectif c'est de pouvoir proposer
d'ici cinq ans à tous une voiture
familiale consommant moins de 3 litres
et nuit au sens par ailleurs plus d'une
voiture pollue plus sa carte grise sera
cher dans 8 % des cas elle va donc
doubler
pas de changement de la vitesse
autorisée sur les routes mais le
gouvernement recommande aux français de
diminuer leur vitesse de 10 km